dark beer Odin hey David is Trump
deliberately holding press conferences
next to marine one so that nobody can
hear him and you can justify walking
away from reporter questions yeah this
came up on our notable reddit
discussions last week I think that Trump
is taking advantage of the noise
generated by his helicopter when
reporters start asking him questions
I don't know that Trump is deliberately
saying hey here's an idea I'm going to
exclusively answer questions when marine
one is powering up in the background so
that it's hard to hear me at an anytime
I can pretend I didn't hear the question
and walk away I don't know whether it's
that deliberate I don't really care
whether it's that deliberate Trump is
taking advantage of it and this is an
age-old strategy it's the equivalent of
Fox News messing with the other guests
audio during debates
I feel Pat like we are missing out on
this strategy one thing we don't do
during interviews even if the guest is
deplorable and talking over me even when
it's live callers that don't let me get
a word in edgewise we never resort to
lowering their mic it's a tool that we
have in our it's an arrow in our quiver
so to speak but we don't do it and maybe
we should reconsider I mean I wouldn't
do stuff like that I mean lowering their
audio levels or like even have meat yeah
like having me chime in so then it's 200
on one I don't think that would be fair
to them either we want to hear the other
person out but certainly Trump does take
advantage of this and maybe it makes it
so that shows like ours don't want to
play his responses because then you get
all that crappy background noise and
he's yelling like I always hate when we
have to play those clips but we kind of
have to listen
Trump said that he was indicating to the
Justice Department that they must
immediately prosecute Barack Obama but
the audio was so hard to hear because of
that helicopter droning that we're not
even gonna cover the story we'll talk
about something else like how Trump
looked really tall next to some of those
other European leaders that's the gist
of it right it's just it's too much
trouble we can't really hear Trump all
right great questions this week thanks
to everybody any method is acceptable
other than fax and telegram and smoke
signals for submitting audience
questions to the show
you can email them you can tweet them at
de Pakman at david pakman show you can
send them in on facebook at facebook.com
slash david pakman show you can post
them to our subreddit at david
pakman.com slash our EDD IT question for
the show
question for david to answer on the show
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah all of these
platforms are welcome for submitting
questions we will answer three more next
week we have a tremendously good bonus
show for you today which you can access
instantly by becoming a member at WWJ in
pakman.com or by becoming a patron for
just $5 a month or more at patreon.com
slash david pakman show support the work
we do support independent media and get
lots of great perks